in one of the most popular videos on my
channel i explored what we knew about
the outer gods of eldon ring mysterious
god-like entities that influenced the
game world from behind the scenes
despite a number of references none of
them seemed to directly appear in game
their ranks consist of such great
figures as the greater will the frenzied
flame the formless mother and more and
they can be found in close association
with many of the most important and
powerful figures in the game from queen
america to the fire giant to melania
blade of nicola but with such an
influential presence it does seem odd
that we never seem to see any of the
outer gods themselves which may lead us
to the question are the outer gods
actually real or are they something else
some collective creation of presence or
myth are they the stories of folklore
told by the people of the lands between
in this video i will explore a few of
the outer gods to try to find out the
answer to this question are the outer
gods of the lands between real for this
investigation i want to look at three
outer gods the greater will the formless
mother and the rock god and i may
briefly touch on a few others too the
greater will is a prime candidate
because it is the most prominently
featured outer god in the game standing
at the top of the golden order and
ostensibly speaking to us through the
two fingers the formless mother will
provide us with information about how
the outer gods may or may not physically
exist in the world and lastly the rot
god will show some of the most tangible
effects attributed to this lovecraftian
race of godlike beings
and before we get started thank you to
those who support me on patreon and a
reminder that if you enjoy the video and
my content feel free to become a patron
or just subscribe to the channel to
support my work and keep up to date with
any new content i send out any form of
support helps the channel keep going
with that let us dive into the reality
of the outer gods
first and foremost among the outer gods
is unquestionably the greater will it is
the patron and guiding god of the golden
order the main faction in power in the
lands between it is the head which
supposedly controls god queen america
the elden beast the two fingers and the
rest of the order in trying to determine
if an outer god is not simply the case
of a mistaken identity or myth built up
around some natural phenomena we need to
look at both the attributed actions and
influence and any relevant item
descriptions for the greater will it
would make sense to look at queen
america as a starting off point but
despite her comments on the golden order
we hear from melina we never actually
hear america speak directly about the
greater will or see any explicit
reference made between them even when
discussing america and her punishment
for shattering the order enya does not
mention the greater will only that but
even in shackles
she remains a god and a vision's vessel
while merica rebelled against the order
it seems unlikely that she would have
been a god under a being that did not
exist and her words from melana about
searching the golden order make it seem
like she is trying to understand
something greater than her that has
structured the religion she heads all of
this plus her imprisonment makes a case
for the greater will but maybe that role
could still be fulfilled by the elden
beast with the greater will simply being
a fanciful story
so it seems merica will not lead us to
further answers instead let's look at
where else we come across the greater
will throughout the game we first hear
of the greater will almost immediately
upon starting at the end of the intro
cinematic where the narrator describes
the shattering of the elden ring and the
following wars these wars led to quote
abandonment by the greater will end
quote that is where we start the game so
the greater will does get an excuse to
not take too active of a role in the
game's main events despite being the
head of the order
we see from this description that the
greater will is given a fairly concrete
characterization as something which
can't abandon the land we see more of
this in key item descriptions too the
elden star's incantation states
explicitly that the greater will sent a
golden star bearing a beast into the
lands between and the elden remembrance
states that the elden beast was the
vassal beast of the greater will
all of these instances talk about the
greater will in a very active voice this
manner of speech is echoed by enya as
she speaks for and about the two fingers
she says that the greater will has not
abandoned the realm and that the greater
will has long denounced the demigods she
even characterizes the greater will in
real time saying such things as that it
is
and that the fingers are actively
consulting with it however we see that
the fingers go stiff and silent even
enyo remarks that they are dormant
severing our link to the greater will
enya clearly believes that the greater
will is a real tangible thing that can
influence the world or at least speak
through the two fingers but maybe that
is just an artifact of something
naturally occurring within the two
fingers maybe enya is a religious
fanatic of a non-existent god we could
try viewing things that way but it is
hard to look at all of the instances
that refer to the greater will and not
see something real acting
but maybe with at least the greater will
there could be another kind of
explanation i forget where i originally
saw this theory maybe from a youtube
comment so i'm not claiming to have come
up with it myself but the theory goes
that we could see the greater will as a
kind of product of the wills of the
people and the lands between it could be
a kind of transcendental entity that
exists through the collective
consciousness of all the people and
creatures of the world
this would make it real but a product of
people not some independently existing
god figure now this might sound like a
pretty out there theory i know but we
can find some support for it it can find
basis in the fact that eldon ring and
from software in general takes great
inspiration from the fantasy manga of
berserk
there are plenty of direct references to
the manga in previous souls games and
especially in elden ring from the great
sword to the swords monuments to crystal
tears and more and this line of thinking
about the greater will could come from
something in berserk too to not get too
spoilery about the manga in berserk
there is a semi-canonical entity that is
a kind of desired god which represents
the will of the essence of humankind it
is an amalgamation of the subconscious
wills of people something which was
formed from people and then influences
them back in berserk's case it weaves
the destiny of humanity giving reason to
the pain and suffering of the world it
directs the world and the flow of events
which is called causality in the manga
this causality is an extremely central
theme throughout the work especially in
how people seem to either be led by it
or try to make their own fate back in
elden ring with the law of causality as
a core tenant of the greater wills
golden order the similarities make this
theory seem a little bit more plausible
if the greater will operates in a
similar role it could be a real thing
but it is something spawned from the
people and then acts as a kind of
superseding will influencing events and
the flow of the world
even out of the name greater will comes
support for the idea that it is some
form of higher will derived from a
collective will of individuals
that collective will coming together to
override and constitute a kind of
greater will
in this case the being could still do
everything we see attributed to it in
game but we can now view all of these
actions in a new context
though past these thematic connections
we don't have much additional support
for the theory as there aren't that many
in-game revelations about the nature of
the greater will a deeper dive solely
into the greater will may reveal some
things but in context of deciding
whether it is real or not either of the
options we've seen would answer in a
similar way the greater will could be a
traditional alien god-like entity like a
bigger elden beast or something just
larger than that in space or it could be
something seemingly supernatural but
spawned from the immortals of the world
in either case it is still in existence
and influencing the world in a real way
this seems to be a matter of fact and
there seemed to be too many instances of
it acting in game or to be explained
away as myth or folklore but we could
still use some more evidence to really
solidify things so let's look at our
other outer god candidates to see if
they can help paint the picture
at the opposite end of the hierarchy of
the golden order below its sewers and
outcasts in the bottom of lane del we
can find the omen moog communing with
another outer being the formless mother
also known as the mother of truth this
is a more reclusive entity who we only
learn of through its connection with
moog and blood-based weaponry the blood
boon incantation lays out the picture
stating the mother of truth craves
wounds when moog stood before her deep
underground his accursed blood erupted
with fire and he was besotted with the
defilement that he was born into
so we see a connection formed from the
cursed blood that moog was born with the
spell also explains a bit about how the
connection works when it says sacred
incantation of mogu lord of blood thrust
arm into the body of the formless mother
then scatter the blood flame to set the
area ablaze the animation shows the
player or moog seemingly reach into
another dimension and summon power along
with fire and a blood splatter we see
something similar in mogwin's sacred
spear the weapon of moog its skill is
blood boon ritual which is essentially a
more grandiose version of the previous
spell whereby the body of the formless
mother is pierced three times creating
explosions of blood with each thrust the
spear also gives a bit of exposition too
saying as well as serving as a weapon it
is an instrument of communion with an
outer god who bestows power upon
accursed blood the mother of truth
desires a wound
there is the explicit reference of it as
an outer god
so if we were to question the validity
of the formless mother being an outer
god we don't have a lot of ground to
work with as the game does explicitly
call it such though with its connection
to moog being through accursed blood
perhaps we could think of the mother as
a kind of power source or natural
reaction which certain people with the
right blood type like omin may be can
trigger or develop a connection with we
do after all see moog's twin morgot who
was always a devotee to the order using
a blood flame attack in our battle with
him the cursed blood slice is also the
unique skill of morgot's cursed sword
the connection between cursed omen blood
and blood flame may lend credence to the
idea that certain people can connect
with the formless mother
and morgot would have never entered into
a contract with an entity trying to
subvert the order so this could support
the idea that it is instead a natural
phenomena or aspect of the world
this mother of truth could be an active
being with wills and desires or it could
be a kind of feature of the natural
world but in either case it seems to
have some kind of presence in another
dimension moog and the player are able
to pierce its body and cast the
associated spells from anywhere this
would only be possible if these rituals
access another plane of existence or if
the formless mother permeates all of
space
either option would work with its name
as both would have it be formless in one
way or another while we do have two
somewhat distinct options for what the
formless mother could be different but
similar to the case of the greater will
as we had two options for that as well
they both seem to necessitate the actual
existence of the formless mother it
doesn't seem that we can relegate the
mother of truth to just a product of
myth or folklore whether she be an actor
from another dimension or a
characteristic of space in the lands
between she is something real
lastly we have the rock god to look at
an outer god who comes up more on the
peripheral but has quite a few points of
reference and influence the most obvious
of which is the lake of rock we will see
that this lake of decay and corrosion is
one of the most tangible effects of an
outer god helping to cement the idea
that they are indeed real
this is the case because the lake of rot
is likely a direct product of the
rockyard itself and the rock god may
just be rot itself as we learned in my
previous video on the outer gods there
is a sealed outer god of scarlet rot the
blue dancer charm tells us that the
dancer in blue represents a fairy who in
legend bestowed a flowing sword upon a
blind swordsman blade in hand the
swordsman sealed away an ancient god a
god that was rot itself
now this does say in legend so we might
think it is talking about a myth or folk
story but there is evidence that it's
real we find the likely equipment of
this blind swordsman in-game the blue
cloth set the curved sword talisman and
the flowing curve sword all have
environmental cues and descriptions
which make them likely to have been the
gear of the blind swordsman and the
prosthesis where heirloom leads us to
believe that melania a demigod born
cursed by rot was taught and mentored by
the same blind swordsmen specifically
one who had a flowing blade which sounds
just like the flowing curved sword which
is likely the blind swordsmans with all
of the specific references to this god
and the inclusion of real people in the
legends and stories that surround it we
essentially have no room to doubt that
it is what it is described as it was
likely a real entity that could have
actually been in the lands between which
as we have come to learn is rare for an
outer god in some fight or conflict its
stagnation was defeated by the flowing
waters and blade of the blind swordsmen
and it was sealed though it still
influences the world through its lake of
rot and seeming ability to inflict
curses on others like melania as it is
such a tangible being that directly
interacted with the lands between and
seems to have some supernatural degree
of power possibly by occupying or simply
being all the rot in the world some
association in which the rot god has
some connection with any rot that
appears anywhere the outer god known as
rot seems to certainly exist
while i think we have seen from our
listed examples that the outer gods do
indeed seem to be real i can't help but
at least mention in passing the
tangibility of the felgot of the fire
giants and the frenzied flame the fel
god seems to literally be in the fire
giant and maybe the rest of the giants
too from a few item descriptions it not
being in the stomachs of the trolls who
betrayed the giants in favor of the
golden order and it appearing after the
fire giant sacrifices his leg to the sky
it seems literally real and able to
grant power and wreak destruction upon
the world it unquestionably satisfies
conditions to be called real and
something like an outer god with
mysterious power beyond the mere mortals
of the lands between
and of course the frenzied flame shows
tangibility through allowing possession
of dead bodies being summoned by the
merchant clan its knowledge of the
greater will and the one great and most
clearly through its ending where its
power burns the world and urgery it is
hard to characterize the frenzied flame
as anything but an outer god given its
great power and clear desires of guiding
the player down its path
viewing the outer gods as a kind of
in-game mythology is an interesting idea
and maybe some aspects of these stories
surrounding them can be treated as such
like we maybe don't need to take every
item description as 100 literal or plain
fact especially when some of them say in
legend says or so it is said
but it does seem the outer gods are in a
lot of ways truly real and in some
degrees in power beyond the in-game
characters they are gods of great
aspects that generally act behind the
scenes waiting for their time to
influence the world they may each
constitute some different kind of form
being transcendental a feature of space
or simply the essence of an element like
rot with their reality in mind the
search now is to figure out to what
degree each one is real and to catalogue
how they reveal themselves especially in
any future dlc
if you want to come along for that
investigation or support it you can
become a patron on patreon or subscribe
to the channel your support helps me
dedicate more time and effort into these
videos and you can get some perks to go
along with it too like early access to
video scripts and getting the chance to
submit questions and q a's and more
with that i hope you enjoyed the video
let me know in the comments your
thoughts on the outer gods their reality
and any other ideas i talked about
thanks for watching bye